♪ ♪
>> Tucker: HOMELESSNESS IS
EXPLODING IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, PARTICULARLY IN THE
CITIES.
IF YOU HAVE BEEN THERE RECENTLY,
YOU KNOW WHAT WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT.
114,000 PEOPLE RESIDE IN THAT
STATE, SUPPORTING THE NATIONAL
TOTAL.
BILL WELLS IS THE MAYOR OF A
TOWN IN CALIFORNIA.
HE SAID THAT RATHER THAN
FIGHTING HOMELESSNESS, MONIKERS
IN HIS STATE ARE PROMOTING
HOMELESSNESS.
SHOCKING TO HEAR.
MAYOR WELLS JOINS US TONIGHT.
MR. MAYOR, THINK OF HER COMING
>> Tucker: IT SOUNDS SO
PERVERSE, IT IS HARD TO BELIEVE.
YOU SAY THEY ARE ENCOURAGING.
HOW?
>> ENCOURAGING, NORMALIZING
HOMELESSNESS, AND WE HAVE SEEN
SEVERAL LAWS THAT HAVE COME BY,
A.B. ONE OH NINE RECLASSIFIED 70
CRIMES FROM SERIOUS TO
NONSERIOUS, AS RESULT, A
THOUSAND PEOPLE RELEASED FROM
THE PRISONS, A THOUSAND ENDED UP
IN THE STREETS.
IN CALIFORNIA RECENTLY RELEASED
PRISONERS?
>> THAT'S TRUE.
I SHOULD POINT OUT THAT ASIDE
BEING THE MAYOR, I AM ALSO A
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONAL, DONE
THIS WORK, I HAVE A DOCTORATE IN
PSYCHOLOGY, AND I WORKED IN AN
INNER-CITY E.R., AND I CAN TELL
YOU THAT MOST OF THE HOMELESS
PEOPLE THAT I RAN ACROSS ARE
INVOLVED IN DRUGS AND ALCOHOL,
AND A LOT OF THE NEW LAWS HAVE A
LOT TO DO WITH THAT.
FOR EXAMPLE, PROPOSITION 47
RECLASSIFIED AS MANY OF THE
FELONIES, AND SENATE BILL 180 IT
MADE IT VERY DIFFICULT TO SEND
PEOPLE BACK TO PRISON FOR DRUGS
AND ALCOHOL.
A LOT OF THE HOMELESS ADVOCATES
VERY MUCH WANT TO IGNORE
ANYTHING THAT HAS TO DO WITH
HINTING THAT SOME OF THE
ABUSERS.
>> Tucker: IT IS OBVIOUS WHEN
YOU ARE THERE, BUT WHY WOULD
OFFICIALS WANT TO LIE ABOUT
ADVOCATES REALLY ARE TRYING TO
PROTECT THE SYSTEM IN WHICH THEO
PROTECT THE SYSTEM IN WHICH THEL
PROTECT THE SYSTEM IN WHICH THEE
PROTECT THE SYSTEM IN WHICH THEF
PROTECT THE SYSTEM IN WHICH THEL
OR ALCOHOLICS, THEY WILL NOT
AREN'T RICH, YOU LIVE IN A
NEIGHBORHOOD, YOU'RE EXCITED TO
STREET.
WHAT DOES IT DO THEIR QUALITY OF
LIFE?
>> IT HAS BEEN TERRIBLE FOR THE
PEOPLE OF MY CITY.
WE HAVE SEEN AN INCREASE IN
HOMELESSNESS IN EL CAJON, BUT IN
THE BEACH CITIES, OVER 100%
INCREASE IN HOMELESSNESS AND
MANY OF THE BEACH CITIES.
THIS HAS A LOT TO DO WITH
METHAMPHETAMINES, THE INCREASED
IT IS A TERRIBLE THING FOR THE
QUALITY OF LIFE.
>> Tucker: MEANWHILE, CITIES
IN CALIFORNIA ARE CUTTING DOWN
RACIST TREES.
THE REAL PROBLEM.